just like some people will speak about
the Sammy Sosa McGuire ERA this is an
era that will always be talked about in
sports cards when I'm 90 God willing on
some sort of podcast maybe in the
metaverse in VR or who the hell knows
where technology will be 2018 to 22 19
to 21 2020 like that will be a thing was
Kobe that thing that happened back then
a factor what else was a factor and so I
think that's kind of uh that's how I see
it Gary vaynerchuk welcome to sports
cards live how are you doing pal I'm
well brother how are you I'm good I'm
good Gary it only took me about two and
a half years to get you on the show
welcome thank you for making the time I
gotta do something somewhat ceremonial
right off the bat
I gotta grab that take that off my wall
that's been up there for two and a half
years I'm pumped I'm very flattered my
friend thank you thank you for coming on
so listen we don't have a ton of time
I'm gonna jump right in and I want to
get your thoughts on the trajectory that
the hobby has been through since 2019
the national in 2019 where I first met
you through the pandemic to today what
are your thoughts
you know I think it's an industry that
got much broader uh awareness
much like many Industries sneakers nfts
cards
um anything social media like markets
um it's a market that I think is in a
really healthy solidified place because
it went through its underrated period
potentially it's overrated period in
this cycle you know we had the McGuire
era we had the 80s junk wax era you have
these moments where two three four years
but every time you look at it I find
like the industry evolves and gets
stronger sports cards have been a thing
in popular culture obviously for over a
hundred years and have had real
understood value now for almost a half a
century right and so you're good like
any Market it's going to have its ebb
and flow Contemporary Art antiques this
is Coins Stamps you know like things
have their Ebbs and flows I think this
last one was incredibly healthy and
Incredibly vulnerable meaning vulnerable
because like base cards of like
speculative players you know you're
going to get hurt on that you're going
to get hurt on those kind of things just
like I did with Todd Van Popple and
Brian Thomas like Brian Taylor excuse me
that you know that's you saw that
happening during this era which is why I
stayed very narrow because I learned in
my teens and 20s about that on the flip
side the amount of people that have come
into the industry is extraordinary and
so I think the Hobby and I've been
watching The Hobby pretty carefully now
for the last year I think it's at a very
healthy place where it seems like
there's rationale to things versus just
hyperbole
um and you know that's exciting and and
healthy and you know I think um it's
been a moment just like I talk about the
mid to late 80s and early 90s right the
upper deck era just like some people
speak about the Sami Sosa McGuire era
right this is an era that will always be
talked about in sports cards when I'm 90
God willing on some sort of podcast
maybe in the metaverse in VR or who the
hell knows where technology will be you
know that 2018 to 22 19 to 21 2020 like
that will be a thing was covered that
thing that happened back then a factor
what else was a factor and so I think
that's kind of uh that's how I see it
I completely agree with you that the
Hobby's in a great place right now we
had a lot of transients come through
over the past couple of years and I
think those that stick it out will be
successful and some of them left and
we're in a healthy Place uh healthier
than ever those those people that left
they're also chasing real estate chasing
nft like like and what's great is a lot
of people that came in that might have
left fell in love
yeah right like like people don't talk
about that when an industry gets a lot
of awareness Sports is a very revered
thing and non-sports cards are always
around pop culture right like you know
like
I'm just pumped to see how many people
came in to be Pastor buyers and day
Traders
but I've actually stayed you know
obviously I'm I'm aware of how present I
was during that time and you know a lot
of people acquaintances former high
school friends young kids that follow me
on social so many of them have stayed in
a very significant way you know for me
what I I mean I'm I'm looked at all the
auctions this last Friday looking and
I'd bid on things you know that you know
very recently
um and are making my bets I just got
into a place where my profile got into a
place where I realized me sharing things
led to a lot of like you know like just
speculate like just people making up
stories just got muckery and so I was
like look that's okay like you know do
does it suck because I want to talk
about the things I'm excited about sure
but am I am I able to like execute and
go to local card shops almost every
weekend and I'm so pumped for I was at
the national and aggressive way last
year a lot of V friends stuff but was
buying cards for my collection picked up
another PSA 10 Jordan
um I'm also I'm like soap I'm like
already counting down the days to
Chicago and I'm trying to find some
strategies of like how to get back in a
little bit more public without people
speculating on the cards that I buy
yeah I think that's one of my questions
was going to be your with your level of
influence how do you feel about publicly
sharing the cards that you are buying
has it changed all over the past few
years because I see some of the
controversy around you when you do this
and to me it seems like you like you
genuinely love the hobby I see your
passion at the national I one of the
things that attracts me to nfts is all
my wallets are public and people can see
that I don't buy and sell I buy what I
want like and like the things that I'm
excited about are like just very sound
players like I don't try like I'm not
speculating on Bobo or like you know
Purdy you know what I mean like I like
to me I learned those lessons in my
teenage years so when I was buying
Giannis or LeBron or Jordan or you know
the ramp these are like Pele like these
are not things that are like you know
that that was probably what was toughest
for me I didn't anticipate
P you know because I thought everything
I was buying was so sound
that it wouldn't feel like and because I
wasn't selling any of it like I felt
pretty confident but like I get it like
I mean Jesus when there's money involved
there's all sorts of [__] going on and
I'm not naive to my you know the size
and scale of my audience and so I'm
desperately trying to figure out how to
share my passion for it without creating
speculation I have not been able to
figure that out
and so
I'm trying to yeah you know I also have
a fairly big baseball practice in Vayner
Sports and like it's very addicting to
like sign a player and then like want to
buy their first Bowmans because like
you're literally that close to it so and
I think that's pure speculation no
matter how good our draft picks are
you know a Bowman first is as scary as
it gets especially if you go on the high
end you're spending real money on a very
unlikely outcome most prospects don't
get to where you want them to go
um so
I don't know like it's um I love sports
cards it's something that's been in me
my whole life I'm paying actually a lot
of attention to it lately because of the
calm pricing feels more appropriate
right now and I'm trying to be
thoughtful about it and like
and I did well you know you know plenty
of things that I own because I held
everything are way down from their highs
like anybody but I also bought early for
a lot of stuff it wasn't like I was
buying at the highs or speculating and
so like whether it's Kabooms or vintage
basketball cards or like you know like I
feel pretty good about what I have and
I'm excited about you know like building
on my collection going forward
great you said you're paying a lot of
tensions right now you're actually
bidding on some cards I don't know if
you're aware but on uh every night that
every one Thursday per month when pwcc's
Premiere auction ends I come I do a live
show on this channel oh that's cool
bottom great pwcc and we talk about the
items I want to invite you to come check
it out sit in the tune in while you're
looking at it a lot of people do that
it's a lot of fun I will what what time
do you do it at
we go live at 9 30 Eastern because it's
the the extended bidding starts at 10
o'clock Eastern so that's really fun I
will definitely turn around for like
three and a half hours talking about all
the items it's great it's a lot of fun
that's super neat I will check that out
one time right on so where do you see
the hobby heading in 2023 and Beyond
Beyond Ebbs and flows like any Market
that is around Collectibles and art and
things of that nature 2023 is impossible
because we don't really have a good
understanding of the stability or
non-stability of the current economy
like you know every day that 10 000
people get laid off at Google and
Microsoft and Spotify is another person
that makes good money that uses their
disposable income to buy like a card
that they've always wanted that's taking
them off the board that money comes off
the board that ends up dropping the
prices and supplying demand so I think
it could be you know if you told me
cards are down another 30 off their High
be like uh-huh if you told me we've hit
the floor and you're gonna see a 10
increase I'd be like like the logic is
there for me to understand either path I
am not a map you know when I got all hot
years ago I just saw seven to ten trends
that were all colliding at the same time
sneakers was a big part of it I saw a
lot of entrepreneurial sneaker kids not
be able to get inventory anymore and
we're looking for something they could
get inventory for and I saw that clearly
I went to Cleveland National
you know which was what 18 right
I think 17 or 18. yeah 17. all right 17
I think or 18 right to your point 17 I
think and I was able to like see it on
the ground I was like oh these kids are
like you know uh basketball was ripping
hot you know there was just like a lot
of things happening they were just also
in ex I was buying Luca bases at 30
bucks
it was just like the buy-in was lower
um so you know I think that um I think
that
that is not what I'm seeing now which is
like it's super underpriced against the
man that was coming this is more like
it's normalized and now the economic
situation will have an impact you know
and so I would say
I'm guessing down another 30 up a 10 to
20 generalization feels like my super
guess of 2023
uh but that's [__] all right Pure Gas
you know one comment you just said is
that when somebody buys an item they're
now off the board they don't need it
anymore and that's one of the issues I
have with with relying on comps all the
time is well yeah that's the comp but if
the under bidder gets another cut and
gets a copy or the the under bidder
isn't competing now with the eventual
winner so the price might come down
unless there are new participants and
we're getting more and more people who
want to buy them so there's that
snowball effect of the hobby growing
more participants coming in we've surely
experienced that between 19 and 22 now
we're kind of in a place where we're
hoping to to uh retain as many of these
people as we can that's the challenge of
the hobby that I have a lot of empathy
for which is
demand creation versus Purity you know I
have so much empathy if you're a pure
collector literally have no thought of
ever selling your cards
Spike up moments are disappointing
because the things you want go up if you
are an investor which you're allowed to
be that I always thought was super
interesting like that people in the
hobby on any direction like I hated when
people that day traded and flipped would
make fun of collectors I'm like why who
are you to tell people what they want to
do but also on the flip side if you're a
collector you know what do you want like
dictatorship like you don't want people
to be allowed to buy something and sell
it like it's really it's really hard and
I'm empathetic depending on what side
someone sits on it but you know to me
it's kind of like the baseball issue the
culture of baseball didn't allow Bryce
Harper to like build the sports
popularity the humility and the
tradition of baseball and hockey
is a direct correlation to its
popularity and you know one thing I was
fascinated by with sports cards is like
oh there's a lot of like you know it's
almost like people want certain things
from individuals or organizations that
bring awareness to the Hobby but they
don't want other things and that's just
not how life works like you know we
don't get to pick and choose like and so
like yeah like that's what you know
that's what happens like if you're gonna
hair down companies media properties
organizations individuals that are
bringing awareness to the Hobby
you know there's going to be an effect
on how much new attention is on the
Hobby and that you know impacts supply
and demand curves and that might be a
good thing or that might be a bad thing
I don't really I you know I'm very
detached for the get from the garyvee of
it all I'm overly empathetic to people
that
make up stories about me like I'm being
that serious it's because they love it
like when some kid was that I knew was
like telling somebody else like I bought
a bunch of Zions and I'm unloading them
and I never bought a single Zion because
I had a big thesis that he was too
injury prone and it was too high risk
and plus Panini printed an ungodly
amount of product that year is my
thought you know he was like Ken Griffey
Jr to me if everything went well
you know
um that's like disappointing but like
I'm empathetic why like people come from
a place of scarcity and fear
um so for me it's been easy but I've
watched a lot of people
leave a lot of companies leave because
there's a lot of tearing down in the
hobby just like there is in every part
like I don't think the hobby or the
industry has any more tearing down than
others I just think it's small
like when you in politics when you keep
tearing down politics are big in social
media those are big and Wall Street
they're big in sports cards if you turn
away 13 to 50 organizations or people
that could have an impact
yeah yeah for sure so as we as we wrap
up just one or two more minutes Gary you
mentioned you'll be at the national in
Chicago in July August are you going to
be the mint Collective of the Burbank
show in February
no I'm like my schedule's really tough I
want to get to a Dallas show that's been
um I really want to get to a Dallas show
I'm going to some local shows in Jersey
in New York I'm just between family
allocation like I think people forget
that I run a 2 000 person company in
vaynerx be friends is a real real you
know time constraint I got a lot to do
there with building out that
intellectual property uh I'm the the
card stuff I've been by the way that's
been super fun for me the cards and the
friends like two passions of mine
colliding has been super fun but the
national is a commitment that I like
lock in
um and then like I really want to get to
one Dallas show this year that was like
a priority of mine maybe the fall and
then I'm going to like the Westchester
and like northern Jersey stuff so
keeping a you know trying to and
honestly very like I kind of like at
this point in my life it's a little bit
of like this you know like I'm trying to
I just honestly I just want to provide
value and I don't want to provide
distraction and I was really happy the
value I was able to create but then at
some point I'm empathetic that it became
a little bit bigger and then like I
don't I have no interest in creating
anything that people perceive as
negative so I'm trying to stay pretty
Incognito in those shows and then at the
national I want to bring as many people
from my universe to the National because
yeah they may want to come and take a
selfie with me but I'm hoping it leads
to them discovering the love of this and
they pick up a Nolan Ryan rookie from
that dealer or they you know that that
that was incredibly satisfying for me in
the last couple years people literally
just coming driving three hours to
Atlantic City to ask me a business
question
they come they take a selfie business
question and then four hours later like
no interest in cards and four hours
later they came back to my table and
they're like I bought this I was like
you bought a Tom Seaver rookie card it
was my favorite pitcher when I was like
that's when I'm like oh I'm having a
positive impact on the market right on
well I saw your boots at the Nationals
last year it was low-key it was great
your passion exudes uh from me as a
lifelong passionate collector do me one
favor before we sign off give a shout
out to my buddy Jason we call him the
worm dog he's a big fan of yours worm
dog thank you for the love I hope I see
you a bunch of times at these shows and
throughout the upcoming years my friend
right on thank you cheers bro stay well
[Music]